voici les chiots redmi nos 12 Pro et 12
Pro plus le redmi nos 12 Pro sera
beaucoup plus plat tandis que le ré
mineur 12 Pro plus sera légèrement
incurvé sur le côté dans les deux cas on
a un grand écran de 6,67 pouces un
molette 120 Hertz full HD+ on a des
haut-parleur stéréo qui envoie du son
Xiaomi a été malin il y a conservé la
prise jack on va retrouver à l'intérieur
en processeur médiathèque c'est un dîner
City 1080 gravé en ciné au mètre on a la
même batterie de 5000 milliampères heure
vous avez trois capteurs un grand angle
de 50 mégapixels un ultra grand-angle de
8 mégapixels et un capteur macro de 2
mégapixels sans oublier une caméra de
selfie de 16 mégapixels côté logiciels
autour de son bio et 14 basé sur un
Android 12 le redmi note 12 Pro est
dispo en 628 à
399,90 €, 828 429,90 € et 8 256 469 € 90
que le redmi ne 12 Pro plus est dispo
uniquement 8 256 à 4990 personnellement
celui que je recommande et bien c'est le
redmi note 12 Pro en version 828 et si
vous voulez en savoir plus je vous ai
fait une vidéo complète sur Youtube
comme ça vous saurez tout dans les
moindres détail